One of the
big reasons Kevin McCarthy is in
this mess
is because he gave the former
president oxygen after January s
He went down to Mar
a Lago and opened
everything back up for him
when he could have done the oppo
Mr.
McCarthy right now
trying to make his way through a
throng of journalists and camera
can't hear him.
But the calculation
that Trump would always keep
Trump would always be
incredibly popular with the base
And now what you're seeing is
I talked to an ally of Donald
Trump on Capitol Hill
who said that the former preside
is calling some of these 20.
And he doesn't have the juice an
Right.
Something that Gates gave
Congressman Matt Gates
actually even made fun of Trump
in a comment that he made to Fox
When Trump
put out the statement backing
McCarthy, Gates,
one of the leaders of the rebell
wrote Sad ad making fun of how T
tweets, right?
No, I mean, look,
I think at this point, Trump
would have more influence in the
if he were to suddenly say
that they need
to get rid of Kevin McCarthy
or something along those lines.
Because it's very clear
that he doesn't have the power a
to actually give
Kevin McCarthy the speakership.
And, you know, I think the
I don't
if it's an irony
or exactly how to put it,
but this is a moment
where Kevin McCarthy,
the the anger among his supporte
at this group of rebels
is at an all time high.
There are a lot of people
who are supporting Kevin McCarth
who are saying, you know,
we cannot give in to them again
because they feel like
they've spent the last
however many years
giving in and giving in and givi
And these rebels
or the Freedom Caucus or whateve
you want to kind of characterize
this group
keeps moving the goalposts,
keep saying, okay,
we got what we want now. We want
And a lot of the rest,
the governing wing of the conser
are they're fed up with it.
But Kevin McCarthy has indulged
at every single turn
And this is the fruit of that.
So there are let us acknowledge
that there are legitimate things
that this group of rebels
has asked for some of the things
72 hours
between introducing a bill on th
and voting for it.
But McCarthy has given them that
No, I know that.
But here's
another one
from one of the rebels,
Congressman elect Josh King,
who one of the things in his pre
release yesterday
says that when his mentor, Tom
Coburn, served in the in the sea
more than 50% of
all major
bills operated under open
or modified open rules
and could be amended on the floo
a balanced budget
was accomplished in that area to
0% of major bills
could be amended on the floor
absent permission, blah, blah, b
But the point is,
that's actually like
a very detailed request.
I want this rule
that would allow us to amend bil
in an open process without the s
just automatically denying it.
That doesn't seem like.
Now, it's
certainly a recipe for more chao
but it doesn't seem like
an unreasonable request.
That particular request
is actually a request
for a better democracy. Right.
Some of the requests, you know,
we want a special committee
to investigate Biden
and we want Matt Gates to have t
or somebody like McCain. Right.
Well, Kevin McCarthy, he's
never going to agree to that.
Something like that.
God forbid,
our elected representatives, Dem
or Republicans, actually
have to go to the floor
and debate policy. Right.
And vote on amendments. Right.
But the leadership doesn't want
If you're Kevin McCarthy
you don't want that
because you're majority so narro
that the Democrats
could actually pass amendments.
They would only need to find a h
of Republicans
to go with them to pass amendmen
So as a power play,
Speaker McCarthy doesn't want th
But to the Trump point,
Trump is popular
with the base and he's popular
with most House Republicans.
There's a huge difference betwee
and powerful.
Trump is not powerful anymore,
and they don't see him as powerf
They do not fear him.
The other message, yes,
the main thing they want
is Kevin McCarthy scalp
because they view him as the K S
But they're also sending a messa
to everybody else
that we will have
a speaker of the month club
unless you give us more power,
because we will have the votes t
whoever gets the job.